All right.
Welcome everyone. Good to see you tonight.
It does look a little different around here in the building.
Uh, if you have not heard yet,
we had a pipe burst in the bathroom right back there on the
other side of the classrooms and side of the wall.
And it flooded all of those classrooms there
down into here, which is why you see this that way.
All over the lobby. Actually made it into the cafe area
and then down into the preschool
area just a little bit as well.
So that's great.
We're gonna have to figure out how
that works over the next couple of weeks, probably.
Um, taking up carpet, drywall, those kind of things.
So that's what's happening over the next few weeks.
So let's be flexible in the ways we need to move groups
around, because those rooms in there are
especially affected.
And so just be aware as we come in on Sunday, things moving
around, furniture different, all of that.
Um, it's a sad deal, but, uh, the Lord is still good in it.
So we're thankful for that.
Uh, tonight we're continuing this digging deeper part of our
Wednesday night, equipping nights.
There are other groups going and classes going.
Of course you can, um,
you can find more information about those on the website if
you want to look into that.
I do have resources, of course,
every week we'll have something, a stack of books
that you can come look at later.
Um, I'll mention one, especially this ones down there,
pretty much the same from last week,
but, um, mentioned one especially tonight.
But again, if this is your first time,
what we do is are digging deeper into
what the sermon was on Sunday.
So whether I or someone else preached it, then I
or someone else will come back on Wednesday
and kind of lead just a brief summary
and then ask some questions of each other.
There'll be a panel of people up here, elders
that will help us kind of process through that,
dig a little deeper into some of the implications, some
of the teachings, and then give you a chance
to ask a couple questions as well.
So lemme pray for us and then we'll get into it.
God, thank you so much for the blessing of tonight
and the opportunity to just come together in a safe place
and a warm place.
And we're thankful that we have the opportunity.
We don't take that for granted.
And may we steward that well use it well,
and that we would be humble before you and,
and realize that you've given us this privilege, not just
for our own edification,
but for the benefit of others as well,
for your kingdom's purpose.
And so, draw us to yourself as we know more about you,
but also then lead us to, to be your ambassadors
in your power, called by you, equipped by you, uh,
that we can do those things.
Not because we in ourselves have the strength, but
because you are God overall
and in us as believers for your purposes.
So thank you for that. God, help us tonight
to see you understand a little bit more about you,
that we would love you more.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
So our big rock this week was, uh,
what we called the attributes of God, God's attributes.
Uh, what describes his perfect, his character qualities, uh,
who, who he is, his essence, his personality, you might say.
And just as, as best we can in our limited language, be able
to explain what we can about him.
Now, we need to remember a couple things
as we get into this tonight.
Just a, as a reminder.
First, when we talk about the attributes of God,
we're not talking about components of God.
Like when you think about water being a compound
of two hydrogens
and one oxygen put together that makes water, God is not
like, uh, this piece and this piece and this piece.
You put it all together. And that's God. No.
Each of these attributes describes his total being.
That's a bit hard to understand.
But, but just think about it this way. He is all love.
He is all mercy. He's all omnipotence.
So it's not that part of him is this, part of him is this.
It's all, all of these. So he's not component parts.
We also, second, we can't really know the truths,
these truths about God unless he reveals them to us.
And he has, thankfully, in His word, we talked about
that the first week, the special revelation of God,
that he's told us about himself.
We can know a limited version of God from creation.
But, but in his word, he's told us about himself.
And that's the only way we can understand
these attributes is by virtue of his word.
Now, we can't grasp them fully, uh,
because we're limited in our ability to understand something
that's outside of our understanding.
So we can't know them fully, grasp them fully.
And the only way we can know anything substantial about them
is through his word.
And we need to be clear about that.
This is what one theologian said, apart from the revelation
of God in his attributes.
We have no knowledge of the being of God whatsoever.
But insofar as God reveals himself in his attributes,
we also have some knowledge of his divine being.
Though even so, our knowledge is subject
to human limitations.
So we can know some things about the attributes of God.
We just can't know everything.
We can't know it fully,
because God is,
is more than the sum total of his attributes.
Like even if we were able to explain as best we can,
all these attributes, God is more even then all
of this study that we're doing about the attributes of God.
Riri said that when we have listed all the attributes we can
glean from Revelation, we have not fully described God.
So even if we were to spend the rest of our lives
and generation after generation explaining
and trying to understand the attributes, even then
we have not fully described God.
So we can't fully describe God,
but he has given us language
with which we can speak well of God.
So though we can't, the the tendency,
I'm gonna talk about this again on Sunday
as we talk about the Trinity, which is a whole,
whew, that's a big one.
But, uh, even though we can't fully explain it,
we can speak well of it, right?
So we can understand how to say things
and how to understand and speak of it.
That's not going to denigrate God in a way.
Even though our language is limited, we will still be able
to speak of it well, even though we won't fully
grasp everything.
So that's even with the attributes,
anytime we talk about God, that's what we're talking about.
There's just so much we won't understand and won't get.
But we can know some.
So we saw two categories of attributes.
Remember we saw two was essential attributes
or the incommunicable attributes of God, things
that he doesn't share with us.
And then we also saw the relational attributes
or the communicable attributes, the things that he
does share with us.
So remember, the essential are those attributes of God
that are essential to his being.
They're at the core of how God works, not just how we notice
or see or, or encounter him.
It's just at the core of himself.
And that means they don't translate to us.
They're not shared with us.
'cause it's part of the being of God.
But the relational, the communicable attributes are those
that describe how he relates to us.
So the things that, that in a limited sense,
he does share them with us, though He shows them perfectly,
and exemp exemplifies them perfectly.
We will be limited in those even though we can
relate a little bit to them.
And so, again, just as, uh, illustration, what were some
of the essential attributes, the things that he, uh,
does not share with us.
What were some of those? I'm gonna mention the three
that we studied on Sunday,
but I want to give you just a, a list of others,
other examples of, of essential attributes, various sources
that come up with these.
And there's lists all over the place.
And people divide these, these are not neat categories.
Like one are the two, like they kind
of cross a little bit, some.
And so there's different ways,
but you can think about it this way.
The the other essential attributes you might think
of would be things like immensity, that God is immense.
That word we don't use very often,
but it just means size, right?
Massive beyond our comprehension.
Immensity, immutability, it's a hard word.
Uh, mu mutate is in there, right? Mutate change.
Immutability means he doesn't change.
Uh, he's independent. It means he has no need of anything.
He's self-sustaining, uh, doesn't need us
to give him anything like we saw in Acts 17.
He's gotta feed the, the idols. God doesn't need anything.
Unity is another incommunicable attribute of God,
that he's one, uh, perfectly.
And we'll see that this Sunday with the Trinity.
He's perfect. And we, we will never reach that.
We could never have that shared with us.
But those are incommunicable attributes.
Here's a, a verse one Timothy one 17 says, to the king
of the ages, immortal, invisible,
the only God be honor and glory forever and ever.
He's recounting a couple things there
that talk about God being God.
And we're not just above all else there.
So the three that I talked about on Sunday were omnipotence
potent, uh, omnipotence, that he's all powerful.
He can accomplish his will. He's sovereign.
Uh, that is that power that God has,
that he can do anything.
He's able to accomplish what he desires to do.
Omnipotence, omnipresence, he's all present, located
everywhere, fully present in every place.
Acts 17, he's near to all.
So there's this idea of God being everywhere
and omniscient, all knowing.
He knows everyone's heart, knows everyone thought
knows the past, present, future.
He knows all things actual, knows all things even possible.
So that's kind of the mind blowing part of this, is
that God knows the potential outcome of every decision
that could have ever been made, right?
Like, okay, you just think about your day today, right?
How many decisions you made, the implications
of how that could play out.
But then the next one also could play
out in all these different ways.
God, yeah.
So you start to think about these things
and it can blow your mind.
That also means we are not open theists,
where God is up there merely responding
to things down here like we are, that the pipe burst
and we're like, uhoh, we gotta fix it.
Now what do we do? God is not working that way.
It's not that He's learning along the way.
He is all knowing.
Now, remember, it is difficult, even as I said though, is
for our mind to conceive
how these things could actually be possible, which is okay,
because like we saw with Job, his response to job was that,
I'm God, you're not.
And that's okay. So there's a measure of faith that we have
in this, but it is okay to wrestle with the implications
of these things, to take your questions to the Lord,
to wonder why things play out the way they do.
It's okay for us to, to look to God
and say, how, how is this?
How is this good? How is this work out?
How, how could this have been your plan?
Like all of these things, it's okay to take that to God.
Just do it. In the spirit of Richard Baxter, when he said
that the ocean is not the ocean,
if you can hold it in a spoon, right?
So there there's a measure of us trying to reduce God down
to something we can understand and grasp.
Well then he's not God.
So there's a measure of saying, God's your God, I have faith
that you are in charge working your will.
Things are going to be according to your will.
So that's part of his essential attributes, part of who He,
of what God is, right?
The essence of the being of God.
But what about his relational attributes?
Those are the things that he does
and in part, share with us who are made in his image.
Like if essential is what God is, omnipresent,
omniscient, the relational attributes are who he is.
I'll get into this on Sunday, kind
of the persons of the Trinity.
The, the, the way that we understand and
and experience God, how he relates to us
are these relational attributes.
And I, I mentioned three on Sunday.
I'll, I'll say those again in a moment.
But again, another list just so you can kind
of get an awareness of
what these relational attributes would be.
Various sources, but things like wisdom, again, things
that he shares with us
to at least a limited extent we can participate in.
So wisdom, truth, God is truth. God is wisdom.
God is mercy.
God is peace, wrath
His will, you might say, as an attribute.
In some ways there's debate about that.
But beauty, kindness,
you go through the fruit of the spirit, right?
You could even list out those as as attributes
that he shares with us in a sense,
even though we're not expressing them perfectly.
He does, but, but we can a little bit as well.
But I mentioned three on Sunday,
and those were holiness first.
Which again, holiness is separation.
It's different from other things.
That's what holiness is, especially from sin. God is holy.
That's a separation from sin for Samuel two.
Two, there's none holy like the Lord,
the angels in heaven right now singing Holy, holy,
holy is the Lord God Almighty.
Utterly different is what they're screaming.
You are so different than everything else. Holiness.
Again, there's a measure of of us being able to share that.
But, but not perfectly like he does.
Holiness is one attribute.
Righteousness is another attribute that is
communicable is shared.
And that means that God always acts with what is right.
He always acts in accordance with what is right.
What is just He does what is right. That's righteousness.
Again, we can participate in that too, right?
We know what is right according to what God says is right.
We can be righteous in our actions as well,
just not like God can be.
And then the third one I said was goodness.
That he's the final standard of good.
Everything he does is worthy of approval
and it's good when he does it.
And so, again, God is perfect in all those things.
And we experience those things perfectly from him.
We relate to him as he's perfectly holy,
perfectly righteous, perfectly good.
We relate to him in that way.
But he also then calls us to be those things, right?
Yet here's, this is where the gospel fits in here,
because we can't do those things on our own.
We can't create holiness and righteousness
and goodness in ourselves.
We can't do that. He's gracious in it that he makes us holy,
Which leads us to obey his will in righteousness, which is
what he calls good, right?
You see how how that plays out, he makes us different
so that we act differently so
that it's good according to his standard.
But it starts with him.
It's, it's his initiative, initiative, initiative.
As we go forward, what a gift of grace, right?
That we see him work that in his people.
So quick blast through,
I I leaned a lot on this book along the way.
This is a really simple book, but, but thick
and deep in a good way.
Uh, Gerald Bray, the attributes of God, an introduction.
It's very simple, easy read,
but digs a lot into this as we go forward.
So this'll be down here as well.
But, um, all the systematics
and uh, biblical theologies down here, those kind
of things you can look at as well later.
But here's the thing. We know
questions come from this stuff.
When you start to play out implications, you start
to think about, okay, well, God is that, well, what does
that then imply?
What does that mean? Okay, so
what we should first do when anytime we talk about God
first, there should be this awe of God, kind
of a stunned reality that God is this okay?
What He is who He is. Wow. Okay.
That should be our first response.
But then there are questions that come up, right?
We, we do see some questions that show up along the way.
So I invite Aaron to come up here with me.
Now, I'm gonna ask him kind of a dialogue.
We, we tweaked this from last week just a little bit,
but I wanna ask him a couple questions about it,
specifically about some of these A attributes,
but also some applications.
And we're gonna kind of dialogue here a little bit
because I know there's questions that come up in your head
and we want to answer those as best we can this way, uh,
and provide some applications along the way.
Then give you a chance, of course,
to ask a couple questions as well.
Uh, but, but these are, these are heavy questions.
We start to think about how big God is.
So let's try to, to think through it in a way that allows us
to, um, to faithfully love God more often.
So first, why does all this even matter?
Like why does, why should we study these attributes?
Why is this important? Shouldn't it be
enough that we love Jesus?
Right? Because I, I've heard that actually to my face.
Like, I mean, I love Jesus. That's enough, right?
Like, I'm getting to heaven isn't that base level.
So why does this even matter for us to study?
Yeah. Everything that we do in life is gonna come back
to your view of God.
I like to say it this way.
Your view of God determines your view of everything else.
Your view of yourself begins with your view of God.
Your view of the circumstances in your life.
Come back to your view of God, your, your view of others,
how you perceive others, your view of the gospel.
Everything in your life comes back to who is God.
And so that, that question of, uh, your view
of God, determining your view of everything else is key.
It's one of those big rocks. We have to start with God.
And so I love that we've gone from revelation to
God, because you can't get to know
who God is without first going to his word.
And so you can know a little bit from creation.
I think if we took some time
and we said, how, what character qualities can you come up
with just by looking at what he's made?
We could come up with some character qualities,
but you can't know them in detail, as John said,
without going to his word.
So I love that we've connected revelation to,
to God's attributes.
But again, why is this important?
Because all the other things we talk about
after this, uh, rock, this tear,
this issue, are all gonna come back and hinge on who is God.
So once, one more time, you know, your view
of God determines your view of everything else.
And so we have to start there.
And, um, that's why this is important.
Yeah. And I, I've heard that one, what comes
to mind when you think about God is your view of God.
So what we're trying to do with his word is
create a picture of
who he is when we think about who he is, right?
You see what I mean? Like, if you think about God
and your first thought is like aggressive tyrant,
that's your view of who God is, then, then
that's the way it's gonna color
everything else in your life.
But if you see God as passive and soft
and just like unable to really do much of anything, kind
of the old Jesus film where he's sitting on the rock,
he's got conditioned hair
and he's sitting there just like can't do anything.
If that's your view of God, then,
then you're also gonna hit some things in your life.
Where can God really help? I don't know.
Does he have the power to do that?
So what comes to mind when you think about
God is your view of God.
And so we want that to be formed by God's word,
even if it needs to adjust some
of our things in our heads. So
I kept waiting for you to hit Providence.
You never talked about the providence of God.
I probably didn't talk about 40, so
I know it's my favorite attribute.
I said sovereignty, but but go ahead. Yeah,
Yeah. My favorite attribute
of God,
and there's, there's the list is,
you know, on and on and on.
Uh, but providence of God,
you don't see the word providence in scripture.
Uh, but the, the idea
of providence is all, you know, every page of the Bible.
This idea that God works all things
for his good, you all know that.
But the providence of God is another.
It's probably my favorite attribute
because he can take all of our decisions
and all of our actions in a day
and somehow work them all to fulfill his purposes.
And, and how he does that, I don't know.
And that's probably why I'm so fascinated by it.
But even the, the, the good things from your life, the,
the things you don't understand, the things that are,
you would consider bad, all of those things.
He somehow works out in his plan.
He has this plan, he has a good plan.
He's, he's using you and his plan,
and somehow he works all these out for, for his good.
I think that's just, that's, to me, that is just, wow.
You have to be God to do that.
And so that's my favorite attribute of God.
I actually have that, that's kind
of a little wrap up of tonight.
So I was looking ahead, you still,
but it wasn't, Providence wasn't, it was Romans 8 28,
which is, you know, that common verse that we'll talk about,
because I wanted to kind of see
how the questions went, but perfect.
So let's talk about another one.
You mentioned that one that, that I didn't mention
or we didn't talk about on Sunday.
At least I mentioned tonight God's immutability,
that he doesn't change.
Uh, so why does that matter so much to our faith?
I mean, okay, great, God changes,
not changes doesn't really matter.
Why does it matter that God doesn't change?
Uh, that's a good question. The Bible tells us God's the
same yesterday, today, and tomorrow.
He never changes. And why is that important to
our faith, is the question.
Um, we're reading, uh, his word,
which is thousands of years old,
and he's describing himself, you know, 6,000,
10,000 years ago.
But he's the same God that he was then.
And so when we read about his character
or how he deals with people, then
it's the same God we're dealing with today.
He does not change.
And so, uh, everything that,
all these qualities, these character qualities
of God are the same.
Wherever God is intervening
4,000 years ago, 2000 years ago, yesterday, today,
and a thousand years from now, he's the same.
And that means a lot to us who, you know,
we readily change our minds.
We, we readily are unfaithful.
We change, you know, on any given day.
But even though we are sometimes unfaithful, he is faithful
and he is always going to be the same.
I can trust him today to be exactly
what he was then.
He's the same God we sing that song on Sundays.
He's the same God as he was then today.
And so to me, that is the immutability of God.
You can always trust him to be who he is,
who he was, who he is.
You can always trust him, always keep him at his word
because he doesn't change.
And to me, that's a, that's a reassurance.
That's a, that's a confidence that we can have in our faith.
'cause it's often said that the God
of the Old Testament is different
than the God of the New Testament.
That's a, a common thought.
No, God's the same yesterday, today, forever.
So even though you might read it
and think it's different, it, it's not, you have
to take God as his whole.
Uh, and it matters
because then if God would change, then we have no assurance
that at some point he might change against us,
against his people that he's chosen and, and saved.
He's like, ah, I'm not gonna save anymore.
I mean, if he could change in any way that is on the table.
So we have to believe that he's never gonna change.
Also, here's another practical part of this.
Second Timothy, you alluded to at two 13,
second Timothy two 13, if we're faithless,
he remains faithful.
So we could have used faithful
as another one of these attributes.
And that's important.
Immutability, unchangeability, he's faithful.
That's important because there's gonna be times in our lives
when people are unfaithful to us.
Some of you experienced it very directly.
We need to remember that God never will be unfaithful
to us, right?
So that's important. It's immutability, it's unchangeable
that he is faithful to his people.
He will never not be faithful to us.
You can see how that that gets drilled down
to a level real fast that affects our daily lives.
So that's just another example I wanted to
See. Yeah. And if you take the
flip side of that
and say God does change, he's changeable.
You wouldn't know, you know,
if he's different yesterday than he is today,
and he is gonna be different tomorrow, you wouldn't be able
to put any faith or trust in him at all
because you don't know what to expect of this God
that changes all the time.
So, one more time, it, it is just a,
it's a reassuring, uh, wonderful truth that,
that, that God will never change
and we can trust
that he will never change in the future as well.
Hmm.
So here's another common question
I've received over the years.
God is described as jealous.
That's a, an attribute of God, probably communicable.
We might say that he could, that we can get
jealous as well, right?
So if God is jealous, does that, like what does that mean?
First of all, does that give us license
to be jealous as well?
And then how does that show up in our lives?
Like the proper way we would view jealousy.
So God is jealous. What does that mean?
How does it play out?
It's really a dangerous thing to compare
how we express these attributes
and how he expresses these attributes.
That's good. Um, we are loving,
but our love is nothing really compared to his love.
We're, we're faithful at times. He's always faithful.
So it's, it's, you have
to be really careful when you compare
our attributes to his attributes.
'cause he, we are sinful fall and he is not.
So to say God is jealous is just to repeat
what he said of himself, right?
Um, I believe Exodus 20,
he's telling his people 10 commandments, not
to worship idols because I'm a jealous God.
He says, uh,
okay, time out.
I thought jealousy was a sin. How can he be a jealous God?
Well, we have to be really careful there, uh, to be jealous.
If, if we are jealous, we are, uh, what's the word?
We're, we're envious of what other people might have
or what, what they can do that we can't do.
We have a fear of inferiority to them.
For some reason, God is not jealous like that.
He, there's nothing anybody has that he needs or wants.
And there's nothing that anybody can do that he can't do.
So he's not jealous in the way
that you and I would be jealous.
The way that we need to think about his jealousy is,
and why he, I think relates it to idols is we are worship.
He we're told not to worship idols
because worship belongs to him, not to anything else.
And so he's jealous for our worship.
He, he is jealous for our love, our service, our honor.
And when we worship an idol, we are giving
to the idol something that belongs to God.
So he's jealous. A good way to think about this is a husband
being jealous for his wife.
He sees another man flirting with his wife.
He is jealous for her because she,
and you know, according to the covenant
of marriage belongs to him.
He's jealous. Is that a sinful jealousy
or is that a righteous jealousy?
God is jealous in a righteous way.
Not, not a fallen, sinful way.
So, uh, he's jealous for that which belongs to him, glory,
worship, honor, if that makes sense.
So it's not quite the same.
Yeah. And there's no higher good for us to terminate
our worship on.
And so he knows that's the way
he designed it to be that way.
So then we, when we give that which is designed
to terminate on him to anything else, it's futile
and it's lesser.
Instead of it being designed the way it was
and it going that direction, God is jealous.
He longs for that, doesn't need it, but he longs for, uh,
because that's the way we then experience the most
fulfillment, quote unquote in life, is by doing exactly
what God designed us to do.
So he's jealous in that.
And we give it to any idolatry, it'll lead us asray.
Here's another one before we, uh, get
to some questions you might have as we thinking of those,
we've got, uh, Mike's stands by the way.
So one John four, eight says, God is love,
so love attribute of God, something we can express
to a limited extent, not perfectly like he does.
It's not the same thing.
But what does that mean for our relationship with him first?
Like God is love. So what does that mean for us with him?
But then how does it change the way we treat others?
If it's a communicable attribute, God is love.
Does that look vertically with him?
And then how does it play out horizontally?
Yeah. I love that he says God is love
and he, it is not that God is loving,
God is love.
He's the standard for love.
He is the, he is love.
He, uh, exhibits love and all that he does.
Love is his character.
Everything that God does is permeated by his love.
It's not just that he loves every now and then He's loving,
but everything he does is love.
So when you think of it that way, then those things
that happen in our lives, if you,
if you know God is love
and everything he does is loving,
then even those hard things that happen to us in life,
we know that God is working this out for my good,
but he does it also and he allows it in love.
And so I can always trust that God is love
despite what we may go through here, uh, in our lives.
Second thought I have on that is, you know, John asked
how does it relate to, to us vertically
and then to to others.
He's the standard for love. And his love was demonstrated.
The Bible says over and over again that God
so loved the world that he gave his son, right?
He demonstrated his love for us.
And that while we were yet sinners, Christ died for us.
His love is, is on a level that you
and I can't even fathom.
He loves us with an everlasting love.
And he loves us so much that he gave his son for us
unconditionally, freely, without
any, uh, you know, we did not earn it.
And so this love is a love that you
and I, um, we struggled to to practice.
He demonstrated his love by giving his son
to forgive us of our sins.
But now when we come to know Christ,
he lives in us through his spirit.
Now, God who is love lives in us
and allows us to love others through us.
Okay? So now we, he is communicating that love,
that attribute with us,
and we can love others, uh, through his spirit.
So, um, that's a love that, that you
and I just, we don't, we can't do in our own flesh.
It's an unconditional love.
It's, it's loving those who are unlovable.
Uh, you know, those who don't deserve to be loved.
That's a different kind of love. Agape love.
You guys know that only God can enable us to do
because he is love and he lives through us in his spirit.
Uh, that it's a, it's another level of love that you
and I cannot do apart from his,
um, indwelling us.
And so anyway, those were
a couple thoughts that came to mind.
Yeah, I love the definition
Paul Tripp gives of love, which is willing self-sacrifice
for the good of another even when they don't deserve it.
And even when they could never pay you back.
So think about God is love willing self-sacrifice
for the good of another even when they don't deserve it.
And even when they can never pay you back.
So there's no way we could pay God back.
There's no way we could deserve his love.
And yet for our good, he willingly
sacrificed himself, right?
So that's, that's the picture. God is love.
That's what he is.
And then he says, love your neighbor as yourself
with the same word, right?
The same idea. Love God with everything you are.
And then one John four says, not that we've loved God,
but that he loved us and gave himself for us.
Then he says the very next verse, love your neighbor.
It's like, so the picture of what he does for us is then
how we are to go love others in the willing,
self-sacrificial way for their good,
even when they don't deserve it.
That's true love, right? It's not
that you're just transactionally
trying to get something back.
It's like, you could never pay me
back and you don't deserve this.
I love you. Anyway, that's love. It's a great picture.
Okay, so you have some questions, I would imagine.
And so, uh, I've got one thing to close with, but,
but really want to open it up for questions.
There's a mic over here. There's a mic over here.
Everybody loves public speaking. I know.
So, um, feel free to jump up there and ask
or maybe tell somebody else and they'll go ask for you.
I don't know the reality. There's no dumb questions, right?
Honestly, this, this is, we're way up here.
So yeah, go for it. Is it on now?
It's, yeah. Hi.
Yeah. Alright. Uh, Jesus said that if you love me,
you'll obey my commands.
So can you talk about one attribute
and another attribute kind of combining
You mean com What do you mean combining or
One attribute following another attribute?
So the the, you're saying love
and then the second attribute is
Righteousness. If
you, if you love, if you love me,
you'll obey my commands.
So love and obedience two
attributes that come together.
Yeah. So I would say all of these, so in the godhead,
again, like, what was the quote?
Um, each describes his total being.
He is all love, all mercy, all omnipotence,
so on all the time, like not components.
He's love. And then it's next.
It's this, it's, he's all that all the time.
So really when you think about it, it's,
he's comprehensively all of these things at the same time.
We can't necessarily imitate that as humans,
but you have to say there's a bit of blending that we,
'cause if, if you look at the fruit of the spirit,
for example, love, joy, peace, patience, kindness, goodness,
faithfulness, gentleness, self-control.
Galatians five, When he says the fruit,
that's a singular word.
So he's not saying the fruits of the spirit
are these nine things.
And that's all the fruit
of the spirit are things like these nine things.
And they all come together.
Now, you might not grow in all of these equally,
you might say, because we're, you know,
we're sinful, fallen humans.
But, but there's a measure of, as I go towards Christ,
into the image of Christ who did those perfectly,
I will exemplify those perfectly.
So that's the kind of the essence there of
as you grow in love vertically,
they all could, what's the phrase?
Um, all boats rise when the
water rises or something like that.
What is that phrase? Somebody know?
Um, the water rise when the tide comes in,
all the boats rise or something like that.
I, I don't know, probably something my grandpa
said one day, I can't remember.
But the idea is that they all kind
of grow towards christlikeness together.
Maybe not perfectly equally 'cause we're limited, but
but you can see how there could be a measure of, yeah,
as we grow in our love for God,
we're naturally gonna grow in our obedience
towards God, our righteousness.
That's what the holiness, righteousness
and goodness comes together to show some of that
as we grow in our holiness, as God makes us holier,
we're gonna naturally be more righteous in
the way we choose to live our lives.
So yeah, I'd see that. That's good. What else?
He's got one. Dallas, you can just go stand in line there.
It's fine.
Hi. Uh oh.
So I'm aware that the enemy comes
to steal, kill, and destroy.
And I'm also very much aware that the way the enemy attacks
Americans is different from how he attacks people in Asia,
different from how he attacks people back home,
where I'm from and since God is the same yesterday, today
and forever, and he never changes, how does he minister
to these different tactics, the enemy, this place?
How does he fight against the
different tactics as the enemy?
Yes. Yeah, yeah. Good question.
I, I think I understand the question.
Uh, the enemy attacks us in different
yes ways in different places,
Different times of history,
different ways, different temptations. Yeah.
How does God's immutability, uh, apply to
that maybe I think, uh,
if I'm understanding the question, um,
it doesn't matter what country you're in.
We all experience the same.
We, we all are in our nature the same.
Yes, the enemy may use different tactics.
Well, I don't even wanna say that things that apply,
things that appeal to Americans may not appeal
to people in other countries.
Lemme say it that way. But the temptations are the same.
So we have to go from all these various nations and peoples
and tribes and how Satan might attack them,
but go underneath the surface.
We are all still very much the same with a fallen nature
and therefore temptation appeals to all
of us in the same way.
And so, um, I hope that makes sense.
Uh, nothing has changed about human nature
since the beginning of time.
And so we are all very much, uh, prone to
to do evil, to to be tempted to sin.
And so his tactics might be a little,
his strategies might be a little different,
but what I'm saying is down underneath those is still
lust of the flesh, lust of the eyes,
the boastful pride of life.
They're all the same no matter what country you're in.
Those are the same temptations. Uh,
And there's nothing new under the sun. Does
That make sense? There's
Nothing new under the sun either. So
nothing new under the sun. So, so like, yeah,
it might play out a little differently
'cause they didn't have Facebook 2000 years ago.
Okay, so would
that be considered a different tactic, a new temptation?
Well, vanity, right? That's not new.
Uh, you've got the temptation towards distraction and lust
and that's all been there.
Plus I was the Lord brought to mind Hebrews four
for we do not have a high priest who's unable to sympathize
with our weaknesses, but one
who in every respect has been tempted as we are
yet without sin.
So if there are new temptations of some sort now
that Jesus never faced, then we've got a problem here.
So the essence of each temptation, so to speak, was there
that Jesus would have overcome on our behalf
now plays out differently in the form of
what we see in our faces every day.
But the essence of the temptation was the same.
So I think he, he's,
he's not surprised by anything the enemy's doing.
He, he's got him on a leash like the whole thing, right?
So I think there's a measure of confidence
that the enemy's not gonna toss something in our way
that's gonna be like, oh no, there's no way this got,
are you, you got, are you sure you got this one too?
Or We're good. He's got it and he's overcome it.
Did that answer your question, nee?
Yes, it did. Thank you. Okay, thank you. Alright Dallas.
Alright. Uh, so my question is
regarding providence of God.
Um, if God is completely sovereign over everything in his
creation, how should we view God in regards
to sinful choices humans make if he is in control
of everything and incapable of sinning?
Hmm, that's a great question.
So when you say the providence of God, sinful choices
by humans that affect and hurt them
or others, how do we still square that
with God's providence,
Right? Um,
if humans make choices that hurt other humans
and then God is sovereign over everything in his creation,
um, how should we view him in regards to that?
Some people may think that is God causing people
to do bad things, but we also know
that God is incapable of sinning.
How should we view Jesus in light of that? Yeah,
Great question.
Yeah, that's, that's a good question.
Uh, we still, God is sovereign. He's over all things.
He's also all knowing.
So he knows the decisions that we're gonna make.
Um, he has allowed us, uh, some level
of freedom of choice.
Uh, Adam and Eve immediately had freedom of choice.
He knew Adam and Eve would choose one way or another,
and yet he allowed that.
That's another aspect of his love to allow us the freedom
of choice is to express love to us.
You can have either one of these, even knowing
that we might choose wrong,
yet God is sovereign
and able to use our choices, even freedom
of choice in this matter of sinning.
He's able to use that for his good.
Again, I don't know how he does that,
but, uh, Genesis chapter 50, Joseph is,
uh, you know, you know the story of Joseph thrown in slavery
and ends up high position in Egypt.
And after his father died, his brothers came to him
and they were worried that Joseph was going to
avenge all these terrible things that had happened to him.
And he brought his brothers in
and he said this, look what you meant for evil.
You threw me in a pit, sold me into slavery.
What you did, what you chose and meant for evil.
Genesis 50 20, God has used it for good.
And we see that played out on every page of scripture.
Man makes terrible choices,
yet God is sovereign even over our choices.
You can even roll dice.
The Bible says, and God is in its decision
that takes a God that's sovereign to do that.
And how he does it, I don't know,
but every one of us, he's given us the freedom to choose
every day multiple choices, good, bad or ugly.
And he's able to use 'em for good.
So there is freedom in the decisions
and yet God is sovereign and providential
and he's bringing about good how he does that, I don't know.
And that's why I stand in awe of his providence.
Yeah, Genesis 50 20 says, as for you,
you meant evil against me.
But God meant it for good to bring it about
that many people should be kept alive as they are today.
So that's a tough one to know that. Yeah.
And it's the, it's the question of evil.
Everybody asks it, we should ask it,
but it says what you intended for evil,
God actually meant for good.
Now we have to wrestle with that
because then we look at things, well it's not fair
that they're suffering or I'm suffering,
or somebody else is suffering because of this.
Well, we don't know what God is gonna do with it.
It leads me to this, this last section of
what I was gonna say here.
Uh, 'cause it gets to a lot of the questions about
concentration camps, seemingly early deaths, cancer
wars like, okay.
And, and Aaron said it a couple times, we all did.
I said it earlier. Romans 8 28 says, for those who love God,
all things work together for good, for those
who are called according to his purpose.
Now, for those who don't love God,
let's just take the implication of that.
It doesn't say anything about that
working out for good for them.
Okay? So we, we just let that sit.
But for those who love God, all things work together
for good, for those who are called according to his purpose.
And so it's so familiar to us
and it, if you're in the middle of suffering, like if,
if I'm suffering with my kid, cancer, whatever it is,
and you walk in and say, Hey, Romans 8 28 man,
like God's gonna work this for good.
That sounds really trite in the moment, doesn't it?
It sounds kind of like,
don't you see like this is a lot heavier than that it seems.
So I read an article this week that challenged us
to think about a world that doesn't have Romans 8 28,
that Romans 8 28 doesn't exist.
Just imagine that for a second. Listen to this.
It's, I'm gonna read a a a lot,
but it's gonna be, I think, helpful for this conversation.
Without Romans 8 28, we would not have confidence
that our experiences in this world work for good.
We might believe that some of what we experience works
for harm, that Satan
and God are cosmically, slugging it out with first one
and then the other gaining the upper hand.
We might be tempted to believe that some of
what we experience works for nothing.
That there's an arbitrary element
to life in which things happen that have no purpose,
no meaning and no redemption.
We might gaze at our sorrows and sufferings
and think there's no goodness in this
and no way goodness could ever come from this 'em this.
Without Romans 8 28, we would not have confidence that
all things work for good.
We might believe that some
of the things we experience ultimately work
for good while others ultimately work for our harm.
Or we might believe that some things work
for good while other things are empty
and meaningless, black holes in God's providence.
Without Romans 8 28, we might not see the hand
of God working in our suffering For
where things work together for good,
there must be someone who's working them.
Work requires a worker, we might assume as do so many today,
that an impersonal force like the universe is
ultimately behind our circumstances.
We might even assume that there's no deity
and no intelligent being
who acts out his providence within this universe.
But just cold, impersonal fate.
Without Romans A 28, we might neglect
to meditate on the fact that our purpose in this world is
to serve God's purpose
that we've been called according to his purpose.
We might fail to ponder the truth that if we are called
to experience trials, it's
because God has purposes to accomplish through them
and that we can bring glory to him if we meet these trials
and pass through them with our faith, strong and intact act.
Without Romans 8 28, our suffering would be intolerable.
We might rightly conclude that our sorrows are meaningless.
But we do have Romans 8 28.
God has given it to us a gift of his grace.
Of course, we need to exercise good judgment when we bring
comfort to God's people as they suffer.
Of course, we need to choose the truth
that fits the circumstance.
Of course, we need to ensure we're not forcing a harsh
or inaccurate interpretation
of the passage as many have done.
But as for me, there are few verses more comforting
and more encouraging than this one.
God is working out his good, his goodwill,
not despite dark days, difficult trials and broken hearts,
but through them, Because Romans 8 28 exists.
Those who love God and are loved by him can have confidence
that he's working through all of life's circumstances.
To bring good out of bad light, out of darkness,
joy, out of sorrow.
It's not that God is especially agile, a kind
of cosmic PR man adept at manipulating circumstances,
but rather that he is the planner, the engineer,
the designer who has ordained the means just
as much as the end.
He ordains the calm and the storm, the darkness
and the dawn, the famine and the feast.
This being the case, no event is meaningless.
No situation purposeless, no condition, ultimately hopeless.
God is working out his goodwill, not despite dark days,
difficult trials and broken hearts,
but through them such circumstances are the raw material he
uses to form and shape his good plans, his perfect purposes.
God's specialty is not bringing good from good
but good from bad.
And Romans 8 28 gently tells me that if I trust him
through my tears, he will give me reason to laugh.
If I trust him through my pain, he'll teach me to praise.
If I trust him through my grief,
he'll afterwards show me all the good that came with it.
And through it, he'll show me the precious flowers in the
dry desert, the beautiful blooms against the sharp thorns,
the gentle petals beneath the vicious skies.
For behind every black cloud is a yellow sun bind.
Every dark night, a bright day bind,
every frowning providence, a smiling face, the smiling face
of the God who works all things for good, for those
who love him and are called according to his purpose.
It's hard. We will not always understand.
So I'm thankful we have Romans eight 20.
Let all our business is a quote I found.
Let all our business be to know God.
The more one knows him, the more one desires to know him.
And as knowledge is commonly the measure of love, the deeper
and more extensive our knowledge shall be,
the greater will be our love.
And if our love of God be great,
we shall love him equally in grief and enjoy.
So God, we pray tonight
in light of this,
there's a whole host of experiences of
that kind of grief questions.
Whether that's very directly, personally in lives
that are sitting in this room right now.
Along with that, we look at the world around US history
and we ask
legitimately, how is that good?
And so in our lack,
we come to you as the source,
as our wisdom, as the sovereign
God of the universe.
The one who Acts 17 says is near
to all who call upon you.
So God, we take heart in scriptures like Psalm 23,
where even though not if, even though
we walk through the valley of the shadow of death,
we'll fear no evil.
Not because we're strong 'cause we have it all together.
'cause we know the right answers.
We Will fear no evil because you are with me.
You are with us. Your rod and your staff, they comfort us.
You remind us firmly at times who you are,
that you're there,
that ultimately it's you carrying us God.
So God, I wanna lift up these
who are in situations.
And I know that's true in the size of this group,
that there's someone sitting in a really
dark place right now.
And even that question of how could you be good, God has,
has maybe touched a wound in their soul right now.
So Lord, I pray for them right now.
God give them the Holy Spirit,
be the comforter right now,
the very present.
Help in time of trouble. God, that you are
Lord as as big as, as immense
as we've seen you in your attributes tonight.
Again, may you remind us though how,
how near you are to your children,
that you love us with a perfect never stopping,
never giving up always and forever kind of love.
And You are working for the good of those who love you.
Or we, we acknowledge that that good may not come
until we see you face, face-to-face someday, till we
take off these flesh suits here and
and get new ones when you return.
Jesus,
thank you.
We know that good is coming
and one day there will be no more pain, no more suffering,
no more tears,
no more death, no more questions like this.
It will be as it should be.
So Lord, encourage your people tonight
that it is good for us to see you study.
You think on these things.
Search your word.
God, I pray you for a hunger for each of us to to dive in,
not just to sit and wonder, but to actually dive into your
special revelation to us that you've told us about yourself,
and we can know you and we'd hunger for that
and we would feed on your word.
But ultimately, God, when we acknowledge in the end that we
will not fully understand everything about the mystery,
that is God,
help us walk in faith humbly.
Thank you for grace. God,
thank you that you have met us in our sin,
Defeated it, overcame it
made us holy, righteous good.
Two Corinthians three says, as we with unveiled face,
behold your glory, you change us
into the same image from one degree of glory to the next.
So God, as we look at you, as we, we see you again
tonight in a new way.
Hopefully you have shown that to us in our hearts.
But as we see that, Lord, change us
into your image more Jesus.
One degree. One degree.
Keep orienting us towards that true north.
You're worthy. God, you're worthy of it all.
Thank you for meeting with us tonight,
giving us this opportunity and privilege to study
and discuss and examine you.
Send us in your power and grace as we go now for your glory
and the authority of Jesus we pray. Amen.
Amen. Thanks everybody. Love you.
We're sent.